breaking news uh concerning the home
secretary beth rigby our political
editor uh joins me now beth
what is the story with pretty patel
well mark in the past uh few minutes uh
we've just been sent a letter that priti
patel has sent to prime minister boris
johnson announcing that from tomorrow
once liz trust is formally the prime
minister and appoints a new home
secretary priti patel will return to the
back benches so announcing that she
intends to stand down as home secretary
tomorrow
once a new person has been
appointed and she has written a long
letter to the prime minister which
forgive me i haven't fully read yet
because we wanted to bring you
the break-in news uh she has said at the
end of the letter i congratulate liz
truss on being elected our new leader
and will give her my support as our new
prime minister it's my choice to
continue my public service to the
country and to my constituency from the
back benches once liz formally assumes
office and a new home secretary is
appointed from the back benches i will
champion many of the policies and causes
i have stood up for both inside and
outside of government thank you for the
great honor you have given me not only
making me home secretary but in
supporting me throughout so pretty patel
uh jumping the gun there uh it's clear
that she was not going to be kept on his
home secretary uh the expectation is
sawala bravaman who is currently the
attorney general will assume that post
tomorrow this must be quite difficult
for pretty patel because for many years
she was considered that she could be a
contender to run for the premiership
that she would be the candidate of the
right if you like of the party a key
leading brexiteer that she has been but
actually what happened back in july was
sewella bravmen was straight out of the
blocks announcing her candidacy and it
made it quite difficult for pretty patel
to stand well now she is returning to
the back benches she says uh in her
letter it's been a great honour and
privilege to serve the country
and she talks about the brexit
victory she talks about the july 2019
general election she says we have used
our brexit freedoms to take back control
of our immigration laws with the new
points based immigration system she
talks about her new plan for immigration
uh meaning that for at long last what
the british people want is reflected in
an immigration policy ending in what she
describes abuses of the immigration
and asylum
system she talks about being relentless
in working domestically and
international dismantling the business
model of evil people smuggling
gangs you know that the policy the
rwanda policy to uh send uh people that
come across on boats to send them when
the government perceive that they've
arrived here illegally to deport them to
rwanda as asylum seekers has been
extremely controversial and has failed
to get off really off the ground due to
legal challenges that will be a key task
i'm told of the liz trust administration
to get that policy up and running
something that both candidates talked a
lot about
in the campaign and just skimming the
letter she also
talks about to the prime minister she
says under your leadership we have made
our country safe for strengthened law
and order deliver our manifesto
commitments and laid strong foundations
for our successors at number 10 and in
the home office to build on so there she
is you can see her in your screens there
pretty patel a key
lieutenant of boris johnson
a key ally of his but aware that there
will be no place for her in a liz trust
cabinet
so she is announcing on her terms her
intention to step down priti patel never
said during the whole leadership
election who she was back in she is
going back to the back benches and it
will be another big beast of the party
on the back benches dominic rabb saying
earlier today that he is certain that he
too will have to go back to the back
benches so pretty patel will join him
we'll find out tomorrow uh who else who
supported rishi sunak who too is likely
to go back to the back benches who of
them will be on the back benches and how
difficult or easy will they make life
for the new prime minister who will be
anointed tomorrow liz truss